Streitpunkt Berliner Wohnungsmarkt –
hier lockt das große Geld.
Wer’s sich leisten kann, Immobilien zu
kaufen, profitiert von steigenden Preisen.
Allerdings: Viele Berliner leben in Angst,
ihr Zuhause zu verlieren.
Denn die Mieten sind explodiert.
12 Euro pro Quadratmeter
bei Neuvermietungen – in der Innenstadt
ist das keine Seltenheit mehr.
Jenny Kopf zahlt unter vier Euro
pro Quadratmeter –
ihr Mietvertrag ist fast 30 Jahre alt.
Ihr Problem:
Das Haus muss dringend saniert werden.
Sie haben’s ja gesehen: Dach ist undicht,
Fassade muss gemacht werden,
viele haben noch Ofenheizungen.
Die müssen gemacht werden,
aber ich trau mich auch nicht zu sagen,
weil dann heißt es: Ach ja, schön,
dann können wir ja gleich loslegen.
Und dann kann er gleich die Miete …, ne?
Mehr Miete? Dann bliebe nicht genug
zum Leben, sagt Jenny Kopf.
Sie würde sich verkleinern, aber
auch das geht nicht.
Selbst kleinere Wohnungen sind in
ihrem Stadtteil inzwischen teurer.
Wo sollen wir bleiben?
Ja, gibt vielleicht einige, die jetzt noch …
Studenten haben wir hier auch noch im Haus,
ja gut, vielleicht wenn die Glück haben,
wenn die fertig studiert haben,
die verdienen vielleicht genug, dass sie
die Miete bezahlen können.
Aber ich nicht. Und einige hier auch nicht.
Ganze viele hier im Haus nicht.
Das Haus im Berliner Norden hat gerade
den Besitzer gewechselt.
Seit wenigen Monaten gehört es dem
Immobilienunternehmer Jakob Mähren.
Schon vor zwei Jahren hat er mit uns über
den Berliner Wohnungsmarkt gesprochen.
Als Immobilienhai sieht er sich nicht.
Seine Mieter seien für ihn Partner, sagt er.
So erklärt er seine Geschäftspolitik.
Unser Geschäftsmodell basiert nicht darauf,
dass wir den Mieter rauswerfen
und die Wohnung dann verkaufen,
sondern im Gegenteil:
Ohne den Mieter könnten wir dieses
Geschäft nicht betreiben.
In der Regel tun wir was für den Mieter.
Wir entwickeln das Haus,
wir machen eigentlich
das gesamte Objekt wohnlicher.
Ja, und wenn das Objekt Leerstand hat
oder auch Leerstand bekommt,
weil einfach Leute kündigen oder ausziehen,
sanieren wir in der Regel die Wohnungen,
wenn sie im unsanierten Zustand sind,
und vermieten diese dann neu.
Und dann wird es auch ein bisschen teurer.
In der Regel, wenn wir Geld investieren,
wird’s teurer, ja klar.
Und um wie viel teurer wird das
Zuhause von Jenny Kopf?
Er meint: Investoren brauchen
gesetzliche Schranken.
Baustadtrat Florian Schmidt setzt auf den
sogenannten „Milieuschutz“.
Praktisch heißt das:
Luxussanierungen verboten.
Das Ziel der Regelung:
Einkommensschwache Mieter
sollen weiter im Stadtzentrum
wohnen können.
Das ist aber für die Bauindustrie,
die ja auch gleichzeitig
eine Immobilienindustrie ist – für die
ist das natürlich schädlich fürs Geschäft
und die sagen dann: „Oh Gott, Enteignung,
das ist ja Sozialismus“ oder ähnliches
und … na ja.
Wir haben hier eigentlich nichts
weiter zu tun, als dass wir eine
Stadtentwicklung voranbringen, wo
menschliches Maß irgendwie beibehalten
wird, dass die Menschen eine Heimat haben
und es nicht auseinanderbricht,
was auch den sozialen Zusammenhalt betrifft.
In Berlin brodelt es – die Fronten
zwischen Mietern und Vermietern
haben sich längst verhärtet. Die begehrten
Innenstadtlagen sind hart umkämpft.
Berlin reagiert mit einer Ausweitung
der Schutzgebiete.
Hier hat die Stadt unter bestimmten
Bedingungen sogar ein Vorkaufsrecht
– darf also Häuserblocks selbst kaufen,
um sie gegen Spekulation zu sichern.
Eine Kehrtwende –
vor einigen Jahren noch
hat die Stadt selbst ihre
Sozialwohnungen privatisiert.
Wenn wir zurückschauen in die
Vergangenheit, dann stellen wir
natürlich fest: Es ist ein Skandal,
was passiert ist.
Berlin hat hunderttausende von
Wohnungen verkauft.
Das sind jetzt die Wohnungen,
wo wir mit Konzernen wiederum
über den Milieuschutz verhandeln, dass
sie dort ihre Modernisierungsumlagen senken,
dass die Mieten nicht zu sehr steigen
im Zuge der Aufwertung.
Das ist schon ein absurdes Theater.
Die neuen Schutzregelungen
kommen allerdings spät
und was sie im Einzelfall bedeuten,
muss oft vor Gericht geklärt werden.
Und Jenny Kopf?
Was hat ihr neuer Hauseigentümer vor?
Wir haben bei der Mähren AG nachgefragt.
Die Antwort:
Die Mieter allerdings fürchten Übles.
Sie haben sich zu einem Verein
zusammengeschlossen und
wollen sich wehren.
Mit der Hausverwaltung schreibt man
sich böse Briefe – das Klima ist vergiftet.
Jenny Kopf will darum kämpfen, in ihrem
gewohnten Kiez bleiben zu können.